let's talk a little dancing right now in
the shell is here and next week the
contestants gonna be reliving their most
memorable year so he's introducing what
they choose yeah you know and for
IndyCar driver James Hinchcliffe this
was an easy choice for him because he
nearly lost his life in a terrifying
crash just 16 months ago I was
appreciative of the position I was in
before a man it really drives the point
home when you almost lose it I suffered
a pretty big concussion in it and I have
no memory of the accident except the
IndyCar driver lost control during a
qualifying race and hit a wall at more
than 200 miles per hour anybody who's
seen the video of that crash James is
saying how did you walk away from that
right yeah didn't tickle that's for sure
perfect I was honestly I was so lucky
for those hundred things that went wrong
there was a thousand things I've had to
go just right for me to not only survive
that be able to race again be able to
have absolutely no lasting side effects
how long do take you from the accident
to step back into the car it was it was
four months just over four months it's
crazy they said would be six or seven
but I was motivated so and now the race
car driver is motivated to take home the
coveted Mirrorball trophy
you're this guy over here this racecar
driver
glitter on and you transform ugh
rhinestones it's not just like glitters
rhinestones get a totally different way
more acceptable that's why I really
think that we have the ability to make
that final James dances beautifully
every Monday because of the hard work
that he puts in not because it's a
natural talent he practices every minute
that he's with me and kind of when he's
not with me he's thinking about it pass
on the airport was probably not a good
move yeah the TSA was probably like this
door in the airport now while Sharna
thinks they have a really good shot at
making the finals winning Nancy
different story because they feel like
there's a big stumbling block wrapped up
in a little bitty package but they're
talking about no I'm talking about they
feel this competition story I think
pretty much everybody